I think you can lay a fair bit of what
happened in Israel on Biden's plate
because I I can explain that I guess I
should Bill I know I know that Saudis
were hot to sign the Abraham Accords two
years ago the reason they weren't
pursued more assiduously because it
would have meant giving Trump some
credit for something that happened
during his term I think you can put a
fair bit at that of that at the feet of
the Democrats who didn't bring Saudi
Arabia into the Abraham Accords when
they could have two years ago and I do
think that's because they wouldn't give
Trump any credit for what he
accomplished with the Abraham Accords
and I do think think that's why we're in
the position we're in right now and you
know Biden also alienated the Saudis the
first time that he went to talk to them
and pushed them into the arms of China
and so that's not good that was a big
mistake we had a chance there to make
peace the Democrats and this
Administration and it's Obama it's not
Biden Biden is just a body they do not
want peace in the Middle East right they
don't want a truly integrated Middle
East and they certainly don't want that
if that means Trump is going to get
credit for it